au président
Hervé Marseille pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres madame la Présidente de la
Commission mesdames et monsieur le
rapporteur
en ouvrant l'examen de ce texte je
voulais vous dire d'abord qu'ici vous
n'avez rien à craindre monsieur le
ministre du soft et qu'ensuite nous
avons une seule intention c'est de
débattre et de faire aboutir nos débats
car le débat paradoxalement n'a pas
encore eu lieu voilà plus d'un mois
qu'on ne parle que de cette réforme de
retraite plus d'un mois qu'elle est
commentée à nauséames sur les réseaux
sociaux plus d'un mois
quel est contestée mais elle n'a pas
encore été vraiment débattue par ceux à
qui l'incombent pourtant
constitutionnellement de le faire à
savoir les représentants de la nation je
ne vais pas revenir sur le spectacle
donné par l'Assemblée nationale mais ne
soyons pas étonnés à la suite de ces
palinodiques que le niveau d'abstention
augmente et que nous observions une
progression inexorable des extrêmes elle
est malheureusement prévisible le Sénat
a aujourd'hui l'opportunité de rehausser
l'image du parlementarisme compter sur
nous pour la saisir et s'il fallait
trouver des raisons de défendre le
bicaméricisme certains députés viennent
de nous l'offrir sur un plateau le refus
d'obstacles d'élus pourtant investi par
le suffrage universel et organisant
scientifiquement l'effacement de leur
propre assemblée démontre par l'absurbe
la nécessité d'une deuxième chambre
apaisée
je me permettrai
[Applaudissements]
de commencer par rappeler une évidence
les mécanismes que nous devons assumer
aujourd'hui relèvent d'un choix
collectif quasi unanime et presque
enthousiaste fait à la Libération en
madame la Présidente assassinat a
rappelé notamment par Ambroise Croizat
pour offrir une digne fin de vie à nos
vieux salariés de l'époque nous avons
opté pour un dispositif consistant à ce
que les cotisations des actifs financent
en temps réel les pensions des retraités
cela avait l'avantage d'être
opérationnel immédiatement nous aurions
pu choisir une autre formule d'autres
formes de solidarité cela n'a pas été
fait la conséquence de ce choix que nous
sommes devenus dépendants des fondements
d'un système par répartition
c'est-à-dire dépendant de réalité
démographique en 1945 à cette égard
c'était si vous me le permettez un
exercice qui n'était pas trop compliqué
avec une retraite à 65 ans et une
espérance de vie de moins de 10 ans pour
les retraités c'était un rapport de
quatre actifs pour retraités autant dire
que la solidarité intergénérationnelle
était plus facile à assumer ce qui
n'enlève rien à l'avancée sociale que
cela fut à l'époque au fil du temps le
contexte démographique a totalement
changé la natalité s'est dégradée
l'espérance de vie a considérablement
augmenté de plus l'âge de départ en
retraite a été abaissé si bien que le
ratio actif retraité a changé de nature
il était de 4 pour 1 il est de 1,6 pour
un aujourd'hui depuis 30 ans les
réformes se succèdent pour accommoder
cette évolution démographique
1995 2003 2010 2014 et heureusement que
ces réformes ont été effectuées sinon ou
en serions-nous aujourd'hui probablement
pour solde de tout compte puisque le
ratio est annoncé à un pour 4 pour 1 en
2050 dans ces conditions défendre la
pérennité du régime par répartition
c'est accepté d'en faire évoluer ces
paramètres nous ne souhaitons pas nous
considérons qu'il est inenvisageable de
baisser les pensions des retraités bien
sûr nous ne souhaitons pas augmenter le
coût du travail qui est le plus grand
ennemi d'un objectif de par conséquent
il ne reste que deux leviers
mobilisables soit la natalité soit la
durée de cotisation ce raisonnement par
élimination explique pourquoi nous
soutiendrons le report de deux anges de
deux ans de l'âge d'ouverture des droits
à la retraite et l'accélération de la
réforme Touraine nous aussi nous avons
des propositions pour les recettes et
elles sont assez proches de celles que
j'ai entendues tout à l'heure nous ne
faisons pas oui oui
c'est Jean-Marie vanderenberg qui a
déposé l'amendement nous ne le faisons
pas de bonnes grâces mais c'est parce
que c'est la moins mauvaise des options
raison pour laquelle la majorité
sénatoriale l'adopte en PLFSS depuis des
années nous nous félicitons que le
gouvernement s'en soit inspiré il est
dommage qu'on est attendu monsieur le
ministre je vous reconnais une forme de
volontarisme en nous présentant un texte
de retour à l'équilibre fondé sur des
prévisions de chômage assez optimistes
nous nous interrogerons d'ailleurs sur
le réalisme de cette trajectoire
financière
que le taux de chômage à 4,5% est encore
loin d'être atteint pour autant au titre
de la solidarité avec les générations
montantes et pour éviter de leur laisser
une montagne de dette nous assumons la
dimension financière de la réforme pour
qu'elle conserve un sens une pertinence
elle doit assurer un sol durablement
équilibré nous ferons ainsi preuve de
vigilance dans les mesures que nous
examinerons nous soutiendrons évidemment
les mesures proposées par nos
rapporteurs dont je salue
l'investissement et le travail au delà
notre groupe proposa d'autres
amendements sur le plan des recettes le
report de l'âge d'ouverture des droits
va induire un surplus de recettes de CSG
nous portons l'idée comme la rappeler
Sylvie vermeiller tout à l'heure de
l'attribuer au fond de réserve pour les
retraites nous souhaitons également
favoriser l'emploi des seniors en
complément du dispositif index senior et
du CDI fin de carrière proposée par la
Commission nous présentons une
exonération de charges sur les salaires
de tous les essayer de plus de 57 ans en
miroir en cas de licenciement
l'employeur devra naturellement payer
l'équivalent des charges exonérées par
ailleurs dans notre volonté de lutter
contre les violences intrafamiliales
nous proposerons que les parents
condamnés pour violence ou maltraitance
de leurs enfants soient privés des
bonifications qui leur sont liées de la
même manière lorsque le parent est
condamné pour abandon de famille ou non
versement d'une pension au profit d'un
enfant mineur la même sanction tombée
dans un autre registre au titre de la
préservation du pouvoir d'achat des
retraités nous proposerons d'indexer les
pensions sur l'inflation prévisionnelle
plutôt que sur l'inflation constater
l'année précédente dans un contexte de
forte inflation cette mesure évitera le
décrochage des pensions enfin nous
souhaitons améliorer les droits à la
retraite des élus des petites communes
souvent ils réduisent leur activité
personnelle pour exercer leur fonction
de ce fait beaucoup perdent des droits
et nous souhaitons leur permettre
d'arriver à l'utilisation à taux plein
pour notre groupe il semble
indispensable de rappeler que cette
réforme n'est pas une fin en soi la
bouffée d'oxygène que nous nous donnons
jusqu'en 2030 doit nous permettre
d'ouvrir dans une certaine sérénité un
débat plus large sur l'avenir du système
de retraite la réforme systémique
d'inspiration centriste par point doit
être remis sur le métier elle est en soi
extrêmement complexe dès lors qu'il faut
assurer une phase de transition si elle
devait être débattue à nouveau dans
l'avenir elle ne devrait surtout pas
être associée à des mesures
paramétriques qui rendraient le projet
incompréhensible par ailleurs envisager
une part de retraite par capitalisation
pour le privé à l'image de ce qui existe
déjà dans la fonction publique doit
pouvoir être étudié sans crispation de
principes notre groupe est prêt à
participer à de tels travaux en y
associant l'ensemble des corps
intermédiaires et pour terminer j'aurai
un regret et une proposition un regret
c'est qu'on n'est pas ouvert le débat
sur la dépendance projet longtemps
annoncé toujours
qui me semble prolongée le débat sur les
retraites enfin et on me rapprochant de
ce que disait tout à l'heure notre
collègue broyé il paraît indispensable
d'ouvrir une conférence sociale pour
l'avenir pour évaluer les suites de la
société post covid en effet nous avons
examiné le commencement examiner les
retraites nous avons vu l'indemnisation
du chômage nous annonce une loi travail
monsieur le ministre Attal vous avez
lancé
des expérimentations dans votre
ministère sur la journée de quatre jours
on parle du pouvoir d'achat je pense
qu'il serait opportun de travailler avec
les syndicats à une conférence sociale
pour réfléchir aujourd'hui au temps de
travail à la société poscovid voilà ce
que nous souhaitons grouper espérons que
nos débats soient utiles
monsieur le président
donner la parole à notre collègue Esther
Benbassa